[Musik]
es ist ein dramatischer tag für
deutschland wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck hat die zweite stufe des
notfallplans gas in kraft gesetzt habe
erklärte wir sind in einer gaskrise gas
ist von nun an ein knappes gut die
preise sind jetzt schon hoch wir müssen
uns auf weitere anstiege gefasst machen
eine hiobsbotschaft nicht nur für
verbraucher sollen auch für unternehmen
meine gäste heute abend sind daniel
stelter makroökonom und autor er sagt
die politik kann und will nicht rechnen
ich bin gespannt alexander kissler
politik redakteur bei der neuen zürcher
zeitung er wird heute abend ab rechnet
mit deutschlands corona politik
bekanntlich mein lieblingsthema jaana
ehmcke cdu-politikerin und
bundestagsabgeordnete sie sich sicher
robert habeck muss auch bei der
kernkraft über seinen schatten springen
das wird spannend und last but not least
wobei ich mich wirklich sehr freue wir
haben eine premiere bei vielen nach acht
wir haben nämlich ein viertel nach acht
zuschauer in unserer runde andere riet
er ist unternehmer und hat sich bei
unserer redaktion gemeldet weil er
ordentlich dampf verspürt seine meinung
zu sagen und das schätzen wir
bekanntlich beispiel nachts sehr schön
dass sie da sind harry reid und als
erster zuschauer weil jemand des tages
heute ist karl aut für mich ist er schon
lange der minister der ausgrenzung und
er hat wieder einmal bewiesen dass er es
bleiben will erinnern wir uns einmal
zurück an eine zeit die für viele ganz
schlimm war zweig im winter diese
fürchterliche spaltung die wir erlebt
haben wir haben menschen in gruppen
einsortiert du bist geimpft du bist
nicht geimpft du bist solidarisch weil
du bist bist du bist nicht solidarisch
weil du nicht geimpft wird die zeit bei
fürchterlich und sie war falsch wir
haben ja auch schon gestern der runde
gehabt die gesagt haben ich habe nur
gedacht ich habe nachgedacht und mir tut
es auch leid was letzten winter passiert
ist aber einer der sie das nicht so das
ist unser gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der unterscheidet immer noch
auch jetzt zwischen den guten und den
bösen die sich gegen die impfung
entschieden haben und hat sich erst
gestern über demonstranten echauffiert
und ich möchte ihnen das gerne hier
einmal zeigen
bundesthemen haben dazu keinen geleistet
[Applaus]
dass ich noch gut stellen haben
berechtigt
den gearbeitet haben jesus in der
deutlich belastet sind ihre arbeit hat
keinen fall war
schimpfte wenn sie das jetzt sehen als
politikerin darf ein minister sagen sie
sind berechtigt zu demonstrieren sie
nicht sie haben keinen beitrag geleistet
ist es nicht gerecht das heißt menschen
die gegen die impfungen sind oder die
vielleicht ja probleme damit haben haben
keine berechtigung da zu sein hat ja
eigentlich gesagt natürlich darf man das
nicht und ich habe diese zeit gerade
auch den letzten winter und das früher
wirklich als große belastung erleben
müssen sowohl als politikerin als auch
als mensch sie müssen sich vorstellen
bei mir sitzen völlig verängstigte
menschen auf dem sofa im bürgerbüro des
sind pflegerinnen und pfleger es sind
leute die im gesundheitswesen tätig sind
es sind sogar leute die inzwischen im
ausland tätig sind weiß ich sie nicht
mehr aushalten und weil sie damit
schlichtweg nicht zurecht kommen und ich
habe schon vor einiger zeit gesagt wann
wer befreit diesen man eigentlich von
seinem amt für mich ist das eine
absolute fehlbesetzung
der kann gerne in professoralen runden
auftreten und dort seine thesen
verkünden aber er ist niemand den dieses
land versteht und den selbst ich nicht
verstehe und deswegen wird es zeit für
einen wechsel herr kessler wand befreien
wir diesen mann von seinem amt mehrfache
befragen wir wird in deutschland von ihm
befreien und ihm von diesem amt genau
und er wird würden in der hinterbank
zurückerstatten von der er gekommen ist
dass wir auch schon für die hinterbank
also win win win die frage ist natürlich
wer ist die größere lücke im kabinett
uns mal etwas groß zu sagen da haben wir
ja jeden tag neue kandidaten frau
lambrecht ist ein dauer kandidatin mit
ist von praktisch von null auf zwei ist
die
staatsministerin roth gerückt geschossen
sozusagen durch schlechtes verhalten
beim antisemitismus skandal der
dokumente passiert natürlich das ganz
schlimme ist er desavouiert leute
demonstrieren das ist grundgesetzlich
verbürgte das ging einen feuchten
kehricht an und er unterstellt leuten
die mutmaßlich gegen die impfpflicht
demonstrieren sie seien generell gegen
die impfung und wir gegen die impfung
sei habe keiner sich öffentlich zu
äußern weil er kein beitrag geleistet
habe da kann ich nur sagen abgerechnet
wird am schluss vielleicht haben auch
ungeimpfte pfleger menschen sehr sehr
viel gutes getan genauso gut wie
geimpfte pfleger man kann doch jetzt
nicht sagen nachdem wir hoffentlich
hoffentlich diese spaltung etwas
überwunden hatten 2g 3g 0 g 5 g was weiß
ich noch immer kommt der lauterbach und
sagt na ja es gibt nicht nur die
kämpften ungeimpften es gibt auch die
rechtmäßig demonstrierenden und die
unrechtmäßig demonstrieren er maßt sich
an er macht sich kompetenz addieren ich
hat das ist leiter der rote faden und
ich muss sagen gäbe es nicht noch
schwächere wer schon weg aus dem
kabinett verriet wenn sie das sehen
denken sie gut dass ich deutschland
verlassen habe ich sehe
ich hab so kannst du hingucken möglichst
natürlich wissen was in deutschland los
ist und dann wenn laut aber auch sehe
das ist
gänsehaut sagt sieht auch nicht gesünder
aus der mann gibt auch nicht viel
gesundes von sich ich habe von ihm
wirklich nichts war ein fehler und ich
denke da sollte man mal was macht man
muss wirklich sagen ich habe noch nie
ein so gespaltenes land erlebt wie in
den letzten zwei jahren und die
gespräche am familientisch oder in
freundeskreisen drehten sich immer um
die frage bist du schon geimpft oder
bist du es nicht und sie haben sich am
ende in diese beiden richtungen
gespalten das ist furchtbar für ältere
menschen zerbrachen freundeskreise
senioren haben sich nicht mehr getraut
ihre kinder oder enkelkinder zu sehen
was ist das für ein zustand man konnte
nicht mehr im beisein seiner angehörigen
dieses leben diese welt verlassen das
ist das ist ich finde dafür keine worte
und darf sich nie wieder wird dafür ein
satz noch zu lauterbach wenn wir uns
hier vielleicht sogar eigentlich sein
sollten dass er wirklich ein verdammt
schlechten job macht als er maximal
ungeeignet ist dass er mehr probleme mit
sicherheit als mit dem amt oder noch
genau so viel probleme darf man auch
nicht vergessen es gab bis vor kurzem
eher wieder umfragen wo er nach wie vor
als einer der beliebten minister galt er
ist ja letzten endes nur auf diesen
sessel gekommen weil er das
eigentlich entscheid eigentlich haben
die medien und die pressevertreter ihnen
zum minister
verschiebung ist da der so sehr teuer
interesse ist wohl aber es nach wie vor
glaube ich nicht bei allen so durch wie
es jetzt vielleicht erscheinen mag ich
glaube das problem ist wenig anmerken
zum einen ist natürlich ich verstehe
dass sie gesagt haben dass emotionale
und das wolle stehe weder zeit mir macht
mir sorge was kommt demnächst weil
das grundproblem das wir haben ist wir
wissen gar nicht was wirkt der wahl der
politik die seit über zwei jahren kroner
maßnahme greift ohne zu wissen ob die
wirklich wirken also wir haben da sind
land glaube ich mit den längsten
schulschließungen die schweizer drei
wochen die schule geschlossen wir haben
großbritannien wurde man sah diesen so
schlimm aber wenn wir ehrlich sind die
wahren ersten welle hatten die viel mehr
tote als wir da hatten wir einfach glück
aber die spätere melden hatten wir nicht
da waren wenig besser als großbritannien
und ich habe mir viel lockerer politik
wir sind im blindflug und wenn heute die
bundesminister da tagen und wieder sagen
wir müssten radikalere und
einschränkungen vorplanen von herbst es
fehlt einfach die datenbasis und das ist
das was ich eigentlich erschreckend
finde das eben wir als ein führender
industrienationen
auf der ganzen auf der ganzen linie
versagt habe ich habe meine anderen
sendungen staatsversagen gesprochen
obwohl ich wirklich für gescholtenen
dieser mann ich bin aber der auffassung
was wir erlebt haben in corona ist extra
itar tass staatsversagen und dass der
herr lauterbach sei zwar zufällig quasi
da noch das gesicht hinhält fein und
dumme ist in der tat falsche aussagen
oder ohne unangenehme ausnahme macht ist
schlimm genug aber es ist nicht das
problem des kernproblems viel größer ist
nicht nur lauter brach also egal was
morgen kommt auch der hat keine daten an
agieren aber er ist schon ein ganz
besonderes problem ich möchte jetzt doch
nicht so viel vom haken lassen hier es
war ja gerade die bundespressekonferenz
nach der konferenz der
gesundheitsminister und er hatte es
innerhalb von 30 minuten von 30 minuten
fundamental widersprochen er sagt erst
erwartet eine schwere corona will einen
schweren herbst eine schwere zeit wurde
daten und das heißt auch immer und 30
minuten später sagte er dann ja er geht
davon aus die neue virusvariante seien
nur mittelschwer das heißt also ein
mittelschwerer virus löst eine sehr
schwere welle aus da wird er kommt drauf
angesprochen das geht ihm alles
durchgesagt in zehn minuten was anderes
als vor 20 minuten und das ist einfach
im konvent eigentlich schon mittendrin
indirekt die entschuldigung
doch das ist ein sehr guter übergang
er mag mein thema ist ja auch eine der
schlimmsten long beach phänomene und
nicht nur herr professor doktor karl
lauterbach ist also ein qubit phänomen
nicht nur er bläst also wir die backen
auf und wirkt auf die panik trompete und
bläst also die tuba der angst nein es
gibt leider gottes auch ein team
lauterbach besonders bei den
gesundheitsministern wie sie heute
getagt haben es steht nicht allein auf
weiter flur genauso starke panische
angst getriebenen macht betrug bewusste
töne stimmen beispielsweise die
gesundheitsminister von baden
württemberg und von bayern an einen
grünen politik und ein csu politiker es
gibt neue vorschläge auf dem tisch von
bayern von baden württemberg von hessen
vielleicht auch von thüringen zum einen
der instrumentenkasten soll
nachgeschärft werden ich denke mein al
capone der macht er den koffer auf land
denkt dass er ein stelle drin und es
kommt das maschinengewehr zum vorschein
also der instrumentenkasten ist er ein
folter kasten zweig sind wieder drin
sein 3g masken tragepflicht
abstandsgebot
versammlungsverbote et cetera dass wenn
man alles schaffen und zwar schon am
ersten siebter also am gleichen tag an
dem die evolution erst vorliegen will
das heißt man arbeitet schon vor ohne
die evaluation zu kennen und sogar der
alte gassenhauer kommt aus der
geisterbahn zurück herr mit der
impfpflicht ab 60 am gleichen tag also
an dem österreich die allgemeine
impfpflicht abschafft erklären uns
einige gesundheitsminister im schönen
sachsen-anhalt wir müssen noch mal
nachdenken über die gesundheits
pflichtpartie über die impfpflicht ab 60
die krachend gescheitert ist herwig hat
heute einen schönen satz gesagt er hat
ja gesagt wir kommen später noch auf ihn
zu sprechen es sei ja ganz ganz schlimm
dass er nun die kohleverstromung wieder
aufnehmen müsse es ging allerdings nicht
anders und er sagte das sei elend aber
notwendig für die deutsche corona
politik geht nur die hälfte dieser
aussage sie ist elend aber komplett
unnötig
die union hat ja was die korona politik
zurückblickend betrachtet auch einiges
mitgemacht oder auch selbst gemacht was
man sagen damals war die
regierungspartei hat sich der kurs denn
jetzt innerhalb der partei auch
verändert wissen sie ich sehe da ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht so einen großen
unterschied zwischen den parteien weil
es ist eher ein unterschied zwischen
menschen sie haben in allen parteien die
fraktion angst oder vorsicht wenn sie es
so nennen wollen und sie haben auch in
allen parteien leute die das komplett
ablehnen oder sich irgendein irgendeiner
weise damit schwer tun weil es ist eine
ganz menschlich eine ganz persönliche
frage um die es geht und deswegen kann
ich da sozusagen kann und keinen
unterschied zwischen gleis der union was
die vernunft überwiegt bei der union das
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen haben wir
sind ja damals mit unserem antrag
reingegangen ins register einzuführen
ich habe im übrigen auch damals diesen
abgelehnt weil ich habe mich dem kubicki
antrag angeschlossen für mich war nichts
dergleichen mehr akzeptabel da haben sie
für die einrichtungs bezogen im finale
darf keine opfer auch gegen auf keinen
fall weil ich habe heute auch die
pflegerinnen und pfleger bei mir im büro
zu sitzen die ungeimpft sind und in
gefahr laufen jetzt ihren job zu
verlieren und das halte ich hochgradig
unverantwortlich weil wir nicht den
beleg dafür haben dass eine ungeimpfte
pflegekraft für andere eine größere
gefahr soll sie enttäuscht dass so
wenige dagegen gestimmt haben und die
einrichtungs bezogen pflicht so leicht
einige durchgänge wo ich bin wissen sie
ich bin in solchen schwierigen
situationen immer insofern enttäuscht
als dass ich weiß dass viele meiner
kollegen auch gerne ihre meinung so
deutlich kund tun würden es sich aber
nicht getrauen ihn dafür mit der mut
fehlt ja und was müssen sich nicht wie
ich meine aber stellen sie sich die
politische lage in diesem land vor bei
den grünen ist das tragen einer maske
bis heute noch eine art religion ja das
hat nichts mehr mit dem virus oder mit
einer persönlichen gesundheitsgefahr zu
tun ja so erlebe ich das auch im
parlament im deutschen bundestag und ja
das macht etwas mit menschen viel mehr
also sie sind ein satz wie ein gedanken
vielleicht macht auch noch viel mehr mit
den leuten die sich diese ganze debatte
quälende debatte jetzt wieder antun
müssen und das kommt ja noch und ob für
den anderen krisen die wir haben wir
haben energiekrise ukraine krieg und
jetzt stellen sich gesundheitsminister
aller länder mit hin und sagen liebe
bürger ich war schon mal vor wir haben
auch mal eine große debatte demnächst
über allgemeine impfpflicht statt 60
vielleicht kommt die auch wir wollen uns
noch mal die köpfe einschlagen 2g 3g 0
gar nichts und herz der im herbst dh das
band das die bürger mit dem start
verbindet wird immer grüner auch
weiterhin auf bürger test setzen eine
der maßnahmen aber er riet wenn man
jetzt bürger test bürgerwehr präsentiert
denn die politik noch die bürger
in meinen augen leider nicht mehr in der
art und weise mit mir gehen auch die
meinungsvielfalt völlig und das macht
mich total fertig malliß tätigkeit tun
damit sie sich bessere bremsen ich weiß
nicht ich glaube wir brauchen
tatsächlich irgendwo ein klein bisschen
demokratie reformation eventuell sowas
in der richtung wo ich sagen das ist so
ausgerichtet auf
uns deutsche wo man sich ja fast gar
nicht mehr wehren kann was ist denn da
los ist ich kann nicht in den urlaub
fahren ich muss mich hier völlig
einschränken also ich habe fragen
unserer jungen reagiert dessen sitzen
sie heute hier aber big hat die politik
schaffen konkret wenn sie jetzt
politiker wären was würden sie tun was
möchten sie den politikern gerne sagen
ihr habt
größtenteils völlig den faden und bezug
zu den leuten verloren meine meinung das
ist richtig weh also wo ich sage was das
leben kostet ein unternehmer mittelstand
oder so gesagt man weiß es ja was hat es
letztes jahr gekostet als vorletztes
jahr gekostet was hatte man für einen
scheiß was du nicht wie viel butter
kostet hier was wundert mich auch nicht
mehr wusste auch nicht wie viele
spritkosten jedes jahr also logistische
aussage was ist das für ein oberhaupt
grauenvollen man muss man muss man muss
natürlich mache jetzt schon lange
politiken im deutschen bundestag und man
muss schon sagen je höher sie in der in
der politischen laufbahn steigen sie
gehen ins kabinett sie werden minister
oder was auch immer desto schwieriger
wird es tatsächlich auch den bezug zur
realität zu bewahren und das war etwas
was mir persönlich von beginn an absolut
wichtig war und dafür muss man manchmal
richtig arbeiten weil sie haben einige
privilegien sie können mit dem mit der
limousine durch die bundeshauptstadt
fahren ja und so weiter und überall wo
sie hinkommen wird in der rote teppich
ausgerollt es ist nicht so dass sie in
eine schule kommen oder eine kita und
sofort die leute oder in ein unternehmen
und die leute ihnen sofort sagen bamm
bamm bamm und das wollte ich ihnen schon
immer mal sagen und das finde ich ja
überhaupt nicht in ordnung nein nein es
wird es man notiert ist ein wunderbares
bild gezeichnet und ich muss richtig
daran arbeiten dass man mal die wahrheit
gesagt bekommen das ist auch in ordnung
das ist auch absolut in ordnung weil die
menschen haben natürlich respekt das ist
das ist gut so aber wir müssen wir als
politiker müssen den menschen sagen seid
ehrlich zu uns ja aber dann eine
traurige geschichte war es gut sie haben
im zweiten fall angefangen weil sie
haben so getan als wären die politiker
bevor sie politiker wurden praktische
erfahrungen gesammelt das ist aber nicht
der fall wenn man den bundestag mal
anschauen der grünen-politiker bundestag
verleugnen die sind die ami der freien
wirtschaft gearbeitet wenn sie mal
gearbeitet haben die parteien gearbeitet
oder in irgendwelchen parteien
organisationen
das ist karriere wir haben also eine
politikerkarriere und das sind menschen
die haben nicht erst die minister waren
kein bezug zur realität wir haben schon
vorher kann bis zur personalität weil
sie eben ganz ehrlich wenn sie anfangen
zu arbeiten dann haben die
lohnabrechnung und sie sehen mal die
abzüge und sehen was wir machen müssen
was ganz anderes als wenn sie vom
studium was ich politologie
geisteswissenschaften
alle vorteile ich denke es gibt auch das
gehöre kaufe ich in kauf wenn die tauben
auch nicht missverstehen aber es ist
halt so ich habe einmal geschrieben am
liebsten wenn wir heute fünf jahre
erstmal arbeiten bevor sie sich
überhaupt im im bundestag nicht so lange
trainer einfach zu sagen so nebenher
gesagt man traut sich nicht das zu sagen
haben schneider die grünen abgelegen ich
habe sie so verstanden auch in den jungs
parteiapparat fraktion trauen sie sollen
nicht was zu sagen und ganz ehrlich das
parlament lebt davon dass man debattiert
der künstler kann man aber bei spielen
und wenn man sich kommentare haben die
nur noch das sagen was innerhalb der
fraktionen genehmigt wird zu sagen und
sprechen abstimmen dann haben wir
natürlich an was sie sagten uns davon
abhängig sind wenn sie es nicht machen
dann kriegen sie nämlich nächsten
carsten platz werden so der autor job
und weiß nichts gelernt haben haben wir
dann probleme sie sagen wir brauchen
faire minister und ausgebildet hat und
generell brauchen wir viel druck von
außen ist der manager das geht in die
falsche richtung das ist nur eine halbe
wahrheit natürlich ist die
lebenserfahrung entscheidend für die
frage wie ich mein mandat ausfüllen was
ist auch eine charakterliche frage ich
muss doch wissen warum gehe ich in die
politik wenn ich sage ich gehen die
politik um karriere zu machen dann
bekommen sie dann entscheidungen
präsentiert mit denen sie möglicherweise
nicht zufrieden sind aber
dass muss auch jeder für sich selbst
wissen warum er geht und wenn frauchen
gerne einmal emilia fester sie ist 320
ich habe sie jetzt ja auch schon öfter
als thema gab von den grünen die jüngste
bundestagsabgeordnete
wegen über die eignung der frau reden
weil ich finde ich auch gerade nicht
zeigen dass wir böse aber finden sie mit
23 jahren sollte man schon
bundestagsabgeordnete sein ich würde es
frau fester persönlich nicht empfehlen
weil ich glaube wenn man die ingame 323
mio
naja man muss einfach wissen wenn man
dieses mandat richtig ausfüllen will
dann muss man auch einer 80 jährigen
einen rat geben können und dann muss man
auch hinter seiner meinung stehen können
das habe ich mit 23 sicher hätte ich
sicherlich nicht gekonnt und ich bin
manchmal erstaunt das sage ich auch ganz
ehrlich in dieser runde mit welchem
selbstverständnis mit welcher
hochnäsigkeit menschen aus diese
generation im deutschen bundestag wie
opfer die hose gilt in die cdu
eingetreten sind und dann später einen
bundestag also weiterhin mit anfang 20
als studentin in die cdu eingetreten und
bin mit 36 abgeordnete des bundestages
geworden auch noch sehr früh gebe ich
ehrlicherweise zu aber ich habe mich
dafür fit gefühlt ja nur da zu sein ich
finde wie sie frau gefallen 23 das darf
weil stellen sie meine erste erfahrung
vorher verfahren wenn jemand mit 16
lehre macht und hatte ihre
berufsausbildung abgeschlossen und geht
dann in die folgen die politik warum
nicht
mehr selbstverständlich wir sind leute
und praktische erfahrung viel lieber als
leute mit gar keine panischen spielt
keine rolle spielen kann also erfahrung
nur in gefahr und ich hatte sich sehr
kritisch und das ist halt sie haben
gerade gesagt naja man muss sich wegen
karriere absicht in die politik gehen
wir ganz ehrlich wenn ein politiker
nichts bewegen möchte
das ist
ich möchte meine politik was bewegen
wenn nicht bewegen wollten sollten die
musik kriegen da und wir steuern jetzt
sehenden auges auf ein corona
winterkrone herbst und das wird auch ein
herbst der debatten müdigkeit werden ein
herz des stresses ein herbst der angst
um ganz fundamentale dinge ich möchte
noch mal sagen meint seinem job einfach
nicht ernst man überschätzt auch sich
wenn man sagt ich treibe dieses land
jetzt noch einmal in eine solche reise
kontroverse debatten lage wo wir die
anderen schwierigen untergrunds allen
krisen schon haben wir haben eine andere
virusvariante das wissen wir glauben sie
die menschen machen es überhaupt noch
mit ich das weil ich es gibt große
befürchten dass immer weniger menschen
es mitmachen werden man sieht er in
berlin schon wir haben keine masken
pflicht in den öffentlichen nahverkehr
50 prozent würde ich mal sagen gefühlt
an meiner wahrnehmung halten sich noch
dran das waren vor zwei wochen noch
hundertprozentig mit 91 47
schreiben und das bin doch hier werden
also was werden dann die gastronomen
sagen wenn herr lauterbach ein holodeck
und meine locker wie er sich nennt auch
so ein infantilität manchmal nennt er
sich als manfred manne lucha der
gesundheitsminister aus baden
württemberg sagt wir machen jetzt aber
wieder zweig für veranstaltungen und
weihnachtsfeiern dürfte nicht mal haben
sie angst dass die bürger auf die
barrikaden
ich kann mir das gut vorstellen wenn wir
einige mängel haben wo sich mehrere
krisen aufaddieren und zusätzlich wird
wir noch der umgang verboten werden wir
tests aufgenötigt werden wir masken
aufgezogen werden viele sagen ihr könnt
immer ein buckel runterrutschen ich hab
grad ganz andere nöte und dann haben wir
wie gesagt ein ganz ganz großes problem
und dann droht dieser stadt die treusten
seiner bürger zu verlieren wenn wir die
zeit vielleicht noch haben ein letzter
satz ja sehr gerne an unserer schulen
ist dramatisch das was mir lehrerinnen
und lehrer berichten mit was wir
psychischen beeinträchtigungen wie es
inzwischen bei kindern und jugendlichen
zu tun haben mit angststörungen ja mit
mit mit sich dem lernen verweigern nicht
mehr in der lage sein zusammen zu sitzen
das ist nicht gut was da angerichtet
wurde und wenn ich heute noch kleine
kinder siebenjährige achtjährige mit
einer fft zwei maske auf dem schulhof
rumlaufen sehe dann kriege ich keine
luft von euch beiden nutzer sozialen
medien zu sehen dass eigentlich hoch das
weiß authentisch also bitte faktencheck
versicherte sehr authentisch also 1 1
ein jahreskalender zum als
willkommensgruß einer weiterführenden
schule oder sah man also offizielles
bild von der schule seien zwei mädchen
die sich mit maske umarmen und sie
hatten auch noch irgendwas wie solche
mit gummi kleider um sich wirklich vor
dem virus zu schützen also mann nötig
ist den leuten schon auf und waren
versucht das wäre in lauterbach vor
allem vor dass zur neuen normalität zu
machen er sagte es müsse normalität
werden sagte er wörtlich dass wir alle
freiwillig eine maske in innenräumen
tragen also die normalität besteht darin
dass wir alle das selbe machen aber
freiwillig das ist nicht weiter
jeder verordneten ungeordnete soldaten
genommen sie sind ja ausgewandert sie
hatten ja keine listen auf deutschland
und jetzt sind wieder mit der ersten
zuschauer t silber fiel nach etwa sieben
mitteilen wolle den menschen ganz kurz
zuvor her ich will mich nicht als
winterreifen fühlen dieser vergleicht
mich völlig fertiggemacht ansonsten ein
weiterer grund zu sagen du hast dir
menschen ich hatte mal die die wirklich
naive meinung die hatte ich war wie
lange also die intelligent ist tollsten
menschen müssen unser land nein das muss
so sein sonst funktioniert das ja nicht
ist erzählt ist das land der denker und
dichter und was war schon vollbracht hat
und irgendwie hat man einfach dasselbe
gefühl seit fünf jahren da steckt das
funktioniert und irgendwie nichts mehr
und dann hast du nur noch politiker die
sich um die recht um die reste streichen
streiten weil du trittst keine mehrheit
mehr in dem sinne dann machst du faule
kompromisse dann
dass das funktioniert doch nicht und was
soll man denen dann auch glauben und
dann habt ihr flossen also ich hab ja
auch ein bisschen über das limit
gearbeitet wie viele und hatte dann die
möglichkeit
von spanien aus das ganze auch zu
organisieren weiter es war ja keine
wohlstands flucht war schon einfach
ausgebrannt
nach zwei jahren auch ein bisschen kraft
gesammelt aber in der zeit hat auch
gesehen was passiert denn da draußen im
land unter ist das habe ich das gefühl
von spanien aus teilweise klarer
ich kann mir die spanische regierung
nicht so viel sagen ich kann über den
lifestyle sagen ich befasse mich ja
nicht so mit spanische politik schon
allein wegen der sprachbarriere
da mein corona ja auch nicht so viel
machen können ich habe auch meine
lebensgefährtin elf wochen haben sie
denn nicht ins land gelassen das war ja
alles total verrückt
ich sehe hier nur wenig qualität und
vielleicht noch tatsächlich zehn
politiker wie früher wo man sagt 'die
sieht man den glaubt man das ist egal ob
die bei der linken partei sieht das ist
so sollten diese über die frau
wagenknecht so seien mai sind halt
einfach
urgesteine wo ich sage die haben es
geschafft über jahrzehnte
weitestgehend sauber zu bleiben oder
soll ich dir ins auge und
punkt der anstrengung erhöht
hier kann ich auch sagen der strauß ja
der hat auch dreck
am stecken haben aber der hat halt der
wahrheit
der war was wo ich sage wenn der wollte
konnte er
erlebte er aber ich habe keine ahnung
was da passieren muss ich glaube es
dauert noch lange und was passieren muss
ist dass mir persönlich körperlich gut
geht und wenn ich energie habe bin ich
gerne in deutschland mal gerne meinen
job und ich kann nichts ausschließen
aber das war jetzt für mich jetzt mal im
werdegang wie gesagt haben er habe bis
jetzt war es alles richtig es ist auch
die lebenshaltungskosten kann man nicht
vergleichen da möchte ich einen haken
ich habe nämlich ein paar als
wirtschafts soll es so ein paar capesize
auch mitgebracht schleuning und
deutschland weil ich dachte ich mir also
ich habe immer gesagt so wie man schauen
also ein paar stichpunkte mir
aufgeschrieben will stichpunkte spanien
und deutschland weil ich wollte das land
ein bisschen verteidigen als deutsche
dachte ich mir ich mache etwa die
landesverteidigung in spanien liegt die
arbeitslosenquote bei 13,65 prozent in
deutschland bei 4,9 prozent in spanien
ist das durchschnittseinkommen
vielleicht auch deswegen die niedrigeren
preise liegt es bei
2147 euro brutto in deutschland ist das
durchschnittseinkommen höher bei 3000
sie mal 15 euro brutto und der
korruptionsindex dass da sind wir auch
besser deswegen sicher zu sagen was
fehlt ist die fragen die privatvermögen
vor kopf und spanien höher als bei uns
die spanier sind reicher als wir nur ein
kleiner datenpunkte hatte
jagte und den sollen kadetten
jahresquote ja jetzt können wir sagen
wir haben eigentumsquote und da kam ich
dass die deutsche politik was für die
eigentumsquote sie tut alles was leute
keine ahnung wir haben können gibt's ja
auch in spanien menschen die kein
privatvermögen haben aber jetzt mehr
davon dass ja ja aber wenn wir trotzdem
da sehen das durchschnittseinkommen ist
wesentlich ging die arbeitslosenquote
also 4,9 prozent gegen 13 65 prozent ist
ein großer unterschied ja und herborn
entschädigt und ford macht jetzt die
elektro fertigung spanien nicht in
saarlouis gut macht ja auch sinn weil da
die durch sind das
durchschnittseinkommen wie es nicht
niedriger ist und war die energiekosten
per günstiger sind und weil die
subventionieren und da kommt man wieder
auf touren und auch die these teile
spanien besser ist da ich ja überhaupt
nicht hab ich getan ich wollte nur sagen
daran erinnern das war kein paar zahlen
anschauen ja aber man kann natürlich auf
diese zahlenreihe kann man das nicht
beurteilen weil gibt natürlich wie misst
man arbeitslosigkeit ganz anderes ich
habe dieses freundin besser dasteht wenn
gott es will ja pakete gab es auch nicht
zu dem die kiwis bei uns das restaurant
& co betrifft ja und dementsprechend er
wollte hörer viel weißem man kann nicht
einfach nur als roger wo wir wo wir
besser was ihre these dann dazu wenn sie
die zuschauer und jetzt haben ja gut ich
muss mir auch zum ergebnis kommen
gemeinsame hier auch mein punkte über
dem vermögen wir sagen einfach mal wir
sagen immer billiger sein reiches land
wenn reiche bürger und schaut man stimmt
gar nicht italiener sind reicher die
franzosen sind reicher die spanne sind
reicher wir zahlen aber mehr in die eu
haushalt ein und dann gibt's
wiederaufbau es gibt den tag in der
stadt schulden damit dem diskutiert nur
die italiener könnten ihr start schon
ein problem völlig problemlos alleine
lösen indem sie einfach die privaten
haushalte mehr besteuern wenn sie in
deutschland wenn ich ihnen in
deutschland ich habe jetzt nicht über
die 10 millionen vererben und 52 prozent
steuern weil wir nicht verwandt sind
wenn ich die selben fall in teilen hätte
das 1 5 prozent steuern das heißt da
gibt's riesenmöglichkeit also der
zuletzt in deutschland weniger besteht
dass unser anderes thema aber
prinzipiell aber ich weiß ja punkt ist
ein anderer der punkt verloren ich bin
dafür dass wir hinterfragen ob wir
wirklich so reich sind antwort ist
eigentlich nein und daraus abgeleitet
die frage aufwerfen ist es eigentlich
richtig dass wir über andere dinge
milliarden andere länder verschieden die
eigentlich reicher sind als jedes
umverteilung von arm zu reich und dann
diese länder die mittel auch dazu
verwenden können um unternehmen anzogen
die arbeit wieder auf um es nur noch mal
fest sein der spanien reicher ist als
deutschland nein ich werde dir sein ich
denn ich kenne kein tier ist auf die ezb
sagt die jetzt auch ganz offiziell
es gibt ihrer spanische privathaushalte
vermögen da sind jetzt die deutschen an
die frage der staat kann wir sind eine
frage ist ja vielleicht ist es schlimm
der staat hat etwas höherer schulden hat
aber fahren sie mal sparen durch die
autobahn wahrscheinlich auch eine
bessere infrastruktur und bessere
digitales netz deutschland hat innerhalb
der eu die schlechtes digitalem
angehören muss dh ist so ist auch ihr so
im nützen l kannst du eben teil 1 auf
letzten bergen haben sich gut das
internet wo wir in bayerischen dörfern
schon kein internet mehr hat das heißt
sie haben besser land investiert aber
das durchschnittseinkommen die
arbeitslosenquote schlecht da immer ganz
cool schlechter und mich noch ganz gut
zu verteidigen hier in der debatte ja
ich hab mich ja nicht so leicht
geschlagen für denjenigen der jetzt
nicht reich gehabt hatte kein vermögen
hat ist natürlich eine arbeitslosenquote
von 13,65 und durchschnittseinkommen von
dem sehr gering das muss man schon sagen
es gibt ja in spanien viele schicksale
wo menschen wesentlich schlechter leben
und wo auch das sozialsystem nicht so
gut ist wie bei uns stimmt was übrigens
auch ein grund dafür ist warum die
spanier mehr sparen müssen aber ich mir
geht es einfach darum hier stützen mal
hier und sagen wohin wohlhabenden geht
es besser aber den ärmeren geht schlecht
einstimmen nächste stück nicht bei uns
ist es eigentlich so wenn sie vermögen
einfach anschauen oder den
vermögenshaushalt frauen italien
frankreich spanien ist eine viel
breitere vermögensverteilung
unter anderem deshalb so angesprochen
weil die nicht mehr privateigentum haben
an immobilien zb weil sie mehr selbst
vorsorgen müssen der staatlichen rente
und ähnliche aber daraus abzuleiten wir
sind so reich und müssten deshalb allen
anderen helfen statt bei uns mal die
autobahn zu reparieren und bei uns mal
das bildungssystem auf vordermann zu
bringen und bei uns von den bürgern zu
helfen ihr eigentum zu bilden das ist
die falsche schlussfolgerung mir ging es
nur darum was ich gesagt so schön gesagt
haben wo wir überall besser sind wir
noch vielen anderen dingen besser wir
haben
interessant ist die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit versorgung so
hoch ist in spanien und bei uns geringer
und dann kommt was passiert eigentlich
in diesen ländern die haben das gemacht
was wir auch gerade machen wir
analysieren wie viel zu viel das waren
viel zu viele akademiker hatte hinterher
keinen job bekommen statt
berufsausbildung die duale
berufsausbildung wird auch gerade in
spanien implementiert seit vielen vielen
jahren und das läuft auch sehr sehr
gutes kann natürlich muss weiter
gefördert und unterstützt werden aber
etwa in der tat er sagt zu recht die die
länder sind sehr unterschiedlich der
eine kann das sehr gut der andere ist
wiederum in dem sehr gut es bringt immer
wenig uns dann so pauschal zu
vergleichen
alles gut doch ganz andere regionen sage
ich mal auch von den
lebenshaltungskosten diese zahlen sind
sehr interessant ich hab sie nicht
gekannt es geht nun
bei alicante also comunitat valenciana
schön wirklich bin ich fan und du kannst
in deutschland wenn du drei hunde erste
zahlst du dich erst mal dumm und dämlich
und dann finde man überhaupt einen platz
wurde freiheit mal so wie ich das
gelernt habe machen kannst und jetzt
habe ich 5 und die haben mir werden soll
ich das das bemerkenswerte ist doch dass
diese kleinigkeiten anführungszeichen
tatsächlich zu dem lebensgefühl der
menschen so viele traurig unser land ist
ja und mit lauter aktionistisch und so
unglaublich durch bürokratisiert weil
wir alles und jeden absichern wollen und
das amt führt am ende dazu hilft die
persönliche unzufriedenheit ist aber die
frage ist doch mal auf die allgemeine
ebene kurs zu bringen ist wir haben ja
wirklich ein brain drain von deutschland
aus das ist ja wirklich ist kein
einzelfall der was total exotisches
gemacht hat jedes jahr wächst auch die
zahl derer die deutschland dauert 80.000
dauerhaft den rücken kehren sie können
sogar die zahl und das sind hier nicht
die transferempfänger sondern sind die
leistungsbereiten dem was aufgebaut
haben und die einfach nicht wollen dass
der staat ihn unfassbar viel wegnimmt
und sie darf er unfassbar wenig aus
ihrer sicht bekommen marodes schulsystem
rote straßen schlechte infrastruktur
plus was er auch gesagt das darf man
eben auch nicht vergessen er hat gesagt
sie haben gesagt sie fühlten sich jetzt
auch freier das heißt viele haben auch
den eindruck in deutschland sind wir
verdammt noch mal ernst nähmen und dann
nutzt und auch nicht so lagen sie knapp
an ihm auch sehr stressig wurde klar was
wir haben doch den eindruck dass in
deutschland generell auf alle
lebensbereiche auch im denken eine
überregulierung herrschen und dann
fühlen sie sich vom staat nicht mehr
ernst genommen möchten dem nicht ihr
geld geben sich ihr geld nicht abreißen
lassen sozusagen namens steuer und dann
drehen sie diesem land den rücken zu und
dann ist ein fundamentales unternehmen
was es gibt mir das auch ein
fundamentales problem ist habe ich nicht
gewusst vorher ganz ehrlich dann kommt
dann nach zwei jahren das finanzamt und
fängt mit der wegzugs besteuerung an und
ich denke ich will noch mal für immer
gar nicht verkaufen ich mach doch weiter
das müssen sie erklären immer gesagt man
muss die reichen ihren gewinnen aus den
sie quasi hätte wehrführer heute
verkaufen würden aber will ihn heute als
angenehm in die infrastruktur von
unternehmen in deutschland und dann also
mit dem wohnwagen es gibt ja auch gründe
dafür oder dabei schauen sie das ist ein
wichtiger punkt da gibt es ein ganz
großes problem für viele
mittelständische unternehmen wenn die
ihre kinder beteiligen an dem
unternehmen was wir auch tun sollte weil
sie seine nachfolge sichern und die
kinder gehen ins ausland zu studieren da
kommt das finanzamt auch und sagt lexus
besteuerung und das ist ein massives
problem es heißt wenn sie also jetzt ja
keiner mögliche oder unglückliche erbe
wurden seine arbeit eines unternehmens
sind dann müssten sie in deutschland
studieren und können nicht aber eine
gute universität im ausland gehen und
weise präsentieren der welt sind wir
nicht in deutschland das auch noch ganz
los von benchmarking aber auch
exzellente universitäre zwei von den top
100 sind in deutschland die beiden
münchen alle anderen sind nicht und
deutschland aber die rwth aachen zb
ausliegen chance ist nicht schlecht auch
nicht in topform ist aber auch seine
exzellenz uni noch mal das ja moment das
was wir als exzellenz definieren ich
komme von weltweiten ranking kann sich
was wir selber machen ist dann wissen
wir auch einen gefallen tun finden sie
eine einzige sache gut in unserem land
seien eine sache wo sie sagen ja ich
will das hier ist ja wohl deutschen das
bier sehr gut
noch fragen
wir sollten drin in den themen her aber
sie haben aber sie haben gerade gesagt
sie haben benchmarking gemacht
sie haben herrlichen im prinzip ja und
dann kommen sie uns sagen aber er wird
ja ist doch nach unseren kriterien gut
ist hat der poker müssen global gruppen
und global ist einfach so deutschland
ist nicht der platz wo ich jetzt wenn
die leute sich käufer von vermaß kommen
sagen weil ich gerne an sido sagen da
geh ich hin da ist die die umwelt in
ordnung da ist die schulsysteme in
ordnung dass ich sterben das ist es
einfach nicht es ist kein schlechtes
land aber wir sind drauf und dran ist in
zukunft zu verspielen so wie wir zurzeit
und seit einigen jahren regiert werden
ich glaube ich habe das gemacht mit der
rwth aachen war ich das nämlich nicht
mag ich mag nicht wenn alles schwarz
gesehen wird dann bin ich ganz normal
die immerhin das andere oder wir schon
falsche neue sendung ich versuche ihn
einzufangen
sie haben mir gesagt dass bier das
reicht mich käme in eine kurze bewerbung
sind gleich zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter koch
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 48 55 meinungen von jeder von
uns hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn
bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht rüber zb she works retten seit
august aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darin führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
dreh zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen dem doch auch richtig
durch
nein das konnte zum manko vielleicht
einmal kurz ein
doch das sind übliche anorak träger aus
ich habe meinen beifahrer meine sache
immer bekommt wer kümmert sich darum
niemand ist ja man muss ja ganz kleinen
auch darüber sprechen das ist einfach
nicht fertig richtig wo ist die aufgabe
von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wesen zurück machen direkt weiter mit
herr stelter und dir der politik oder ob
die rechnen kann
ja das können wir gerne machen also
meine kernthese ist meine aussage ist
die politik kann nicht rechnen sie will
nicht rechnen wenn sie unternehmer sind
haben wir eine bilanz da schauen sie was
auf der aktivseite also autobahn
infrastruktur wenig ist das passiert was
ich verschulden was habe ich auch
vereinbart haben und die politik hat uns
zwei jahre lang erzählt schwarze null
große leistungen wahrheit was keine
große leistung sondern sich eine
zinsersparnis gehabt und der
steuereinnahmen ich bin eine zahl zahlen
sind nicht kompliziert aber er wohnt
allein im prinzip schon allein auf
bundesebene hat im zeitraum von 2009 bis
380 milliarden so sich ausgegeben und
darüber nach 140 milliarden zinsen
gespart und 40 milliarden für die
arbeitslosigkeit gespart summe waren es
460 milliarden euro die politik
zusätzlich hat er uns erzählt sie sparen
von 1980 160 milliarden haben 70
milliarden schulden getilgt das stimmt
und 390 milliarden wurden ausgegeben da
frage ich mich natürlich wo das geld
geblieben war auf wie sie dich nicht in
der infrastruktur des landes und auch
nicht im bildungssystem das ist
geflossen in rente in gesundheit in alle
möglichen dinge auch und energiewende
und was im prinzip haben der politik die
immer sagt ja denken dann die zukunft
ist aber nicht tut die politik lebt von
der hand in den mund und das ist das
kernproblem vor denen wir stehen im land
und wir werden es ja die energiewende an
schauen wir nur ein wort dazu dass ein
schönes beispiel energiewende wir haben
lange zeit hingenommen dass wir enorme
milliarden-beträge aufgewendet haben für
die energiewende wir haben seine tun ist
für einen guten zweck wenn sie sich
anschauen den co2 ausstoß deutschland
energie sind wir mit die schlechtesten
wie kann es sein dass wir milliarden
ausgeben schlechtesten sind und dann
heißt es ja müssen mehr windkraft machen
was alles andere abschalten und kohle
und kernkraftwerke abzuschalten und dann
alles auf gast zu setzen was die
bundesregierung machen das auch
funktioniert ändern hat folgen das ist
es so als wenn sie in einem boot sitzen
und sie sehen dass koffer und sie
möchten gerne dass die mannschaft
schneller rudert und deshalb schlagen
sie ein leck ins boot und das ist unsere
politik und das gilt bei energiewende
das gilt auch bei rente herr scholz hat
mal gesagt sehr schön rentensystem alles
ist sicher als ihm vorgerechnet wurden
wahlkampfes nicht so hatte ich hätte
gerne echte experten die suche bis heute
noch weil die fakten einfach es gibt
nicht zusammen länger leben weniger lang
arbeiten und gleiche beiträge und gleich
renten es gibt mathematisch nicht und da
kann man nur sagen entweder kann er
nicht rechnen oder will nicht rechnen
und das gilt nicht nur für scholz das
gilt für die vorgängerregierung und das
bild vermuten auch für die kommende
regierung war die politik andere dinge
gemacht vielleicht haben wir zu wenig
mathematiker bundestag ich weiß es nicht
das ist meine kritik und darum bin ich
besorgt für die zukunft dieses landes
was der doktor stellte anspricht sind
die sogenannten politischen
begehrlichkeiten und ich habe bereits im
ersten semester politikwissenschaften
gelernt dass gute politik vor allen
dingen darin besteht in guten
wirtschaftlich guten zeiten sich
rücklagen zu bilden um für schlechte
zeiten vorbereitet zu sein haben wir in
einer sehr vielfältigen demokratie und
wir sind im politischen wettbewerb und
jeder möchte punkten in seiner wähler
klientel was dazu führt dass wir in
politisch in wirtschaftlich guten zeiten
das geld mit vollen händen ausgeben so
genannte soziale geschenke verteilen den
sozialstaat weiter ausbauen das darf ich
als sozialpolitikerin sagen die seit
vielen jahren in diesem bereich arbeitet
ohne wirklich tatsächlich darauf zu
schauen wie das künftige generationen zu
bezahlen haben und hier möchte ich gerne
an ein thema anknüpfen dass wir in der
runde vorher schon diskutiert haben am
ende kommt es oft dass persönliche
format von politischen
entscheidungsträgern an auch in der lage
zu sein unbequeme wahrheiten
auszusprechen den menschen auch mal zu
sagen wir können hier nicht noch eins
drauf setzen weil es wird einem am ende
sowieso nicht gedankt dann wird immer
noch mehr und immer noch mehr gefordert
und so in das ein verselbständigt sich
das in der politischen debatte und
insofern ist es ein einer formulierung
eines anspruches ich aber ich möchte
eine sache kurz zeigen und zwar heute ja
einer eine unangenehme wahrheit
ausgesprochen eine unangenehme und ich
zeig mir mal das video heute von herweck
wir haben in deutschland eine störung
der gasversorgung so ist definiert daher
ist es erforderlich diese alarmstufe
auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland wir sind also jetzt gehalten
die gasverkäufe zu reduzieren jetzt
schon im sommer dann vor allem mit der
perspektive auf den winter
frechheit wissen sie warum im mai
2022 haben wir so viel gas wie noch nie
in der geschichte deutschlands dazu
verwendet strom zu erzeugen und man
weiter kriegs angriff im februar ganz
ehrlich wie man das machen kann verstehe
ich nicht ich dann hin zu stellen mit
einem betroffenen gesicht dann würde
wahrscheinlich kategorie fallen bei
ihnen mit nach dem motto mainz ehrlich
nein ich glaube nicht als gut ich glaube
ich ganz gut dann menschen auch nicht
von ganz gute von politikern ihr seid
ihr gar nicht wieder verrechnet ich
würde erstmal bei ihrem gesagt es liegt
an den menschen ich bin ganz deutlich
sagen nein ich jedoch an instrumenten
wir haben wir könnten doppelte
buchführung einführen das ist
kompliziert für könnten die bilanz haben
des staates auf europäischer ebene würde
sogar gefordert die bundesregierungen
weigern sich eine bilanz aufzustellen
schon seit jahren meine müssten sie mich
aufweisen da könnt ihr herr heil nicht
mehr sagen und die grundrechte kosten
der fünf milliarden die kosten fünf
milliarden pro jahr wachsen über die
nächsten jahrzehnte dass ein paar
hundert wieder im gesetz drinstehen
nicht 5 milliarden das können das zweite
ist haben wir bundesrechnungshof der
bundesrechnungshof sei legt regelmäßig
die regierung und wissen was die
politiker machen gibt schöne spruch
gelesen gelacht gelocht vielen ist
überhaupt nicht ernst und die medien
lebens gar nicht auf
ernst nimmt und deshalb gehört aber da
frage ich sie haben sich für oder gegen
wieder auch prof bestimmt im bundestag
in der eu
das kann ich gerade nicht sagen das ist
dass ich jetzt ganz übel dabei habe das
war etwas was wenn sie
bundesrechnungshof wenn simone
rechnungshof lesen das gutachten es ist
sind hunderte von milliarden lasten die
da eingegangen wurden dringend davor
gewarnt die politik sagt naja cukas ja
es ist ein riesiger ja nur eine sache
natürlich würde ich jetzt erst mal
spontan sagen ja ist sie haben mit allem
recht man kann nicht rechnen es wird
geld für frühstück weil es auch zum
bisher zum nulltarif nullzinspolitik
gedruckt werden konnte ich glaube es
auch ein ganz großes übel allerdings
muss ich einmal sagen nicht zu
rechtfertigen euch doch zur erklärung
was jetzt hier sehr überzeugend
dargelegt haben könnte man auch mit
einem minuszeichen von anderen
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern vorgetragen
bekommen als gibt auch
wirtschaftswissenschaftliche genau das
gegenteil sagen beispielsweise ihr
kollege frank stadt zum beispiel würde
jetzt ja auch auf zahlen berufen und kam
zum ganz ganz anderen ergebnis gibt
gewerkschaftsnahe
wirtschaftswissenschaftler
arbeitgebernahe wirtschaft und es gibt
auch keine sowie vigier ausnahme ist
wieder voll da sein aber es ist es nicht
ganz so eingängig wie sie es hier
darstellen was mein punkt die politik
kann rechnen ich würde sagen die politik
ist im spannungsfeld von unglaublich
vielen experten und sie lässt sich mal
von diesem mal von jenen beraten und
ganzen zu wenig kompetenz vielleicht
auch zu wenig charakterbildung um
zwischen diesen experten aus zu lesen
man findet für das was man will immer
experten und man findet auch immer
wirtschaftsexperten die dann war sein
habe keine schuld sagen also was
erstellt hat wird er gesagt hat völliger
käse hier sind die richtigen zahlen
macht weiter dass wacker so seien
natürlich recht aber nicht mal anders
wären herr bofinger bundesrechnungshof
man kann sicherlich dass eine
institution die heißt die geht das
kaiserreich gab es das schon das ist
eine wichtige institution der
steuerzahler viel geld dafür in holland
gibt eine ähnliche institutionen die
bewertet sogar vor den wahlen die
wahlprogramme und das wird in den
torschuss mitdiskutiert machen quasi
gutachten zu den wirtschaftlich gibt es
eine tolle ergebnisse bei den wahlen
aber in deutschland werden auch beim
programm bewertet ist also ich habe alle
ich habe wahrscheinlich der einzige hier
am tisch der alle wahlprogramme gelesen
haben spottka ich hab's mal podcast
besprochen die grünen zwei stunden
brauchten sie aber auch dann wissen sie
wir alle gelitten das ist natürlich die
dass sich das wirtschaftlich wirklich
auszurechnen der bundesrechnungshof das
ist dieser herr vater ist nah an der spd
ich habe kein wasser am hut haben
hoffentlich jetzt gemerkt weil ich sagen
wir enttäuscht dh es gibt
bundesrechnungshof gibt so neutrale
instanz nie weiß aus wie von milliarden
fehlen das wäre ein maßstab den
aufzuwerten und es wäre auch ein maßstab
dass die aussaat des rechnungshofs in
talkshows über egal wo sie sind auch mit
aufgenommen werden von journalisten und
das andere ist eben doch in der
buchführung dass wenn dort das sind dass
er heil ich sagen kann es kostet 5
milliarden sondern sofort satow die
verbindlichkeiten deutschen staates
haben wir heute mal gerade so 300
milliarden euro mehr flaschen gehören
jetzt eigentlich gebannt zu erstellen
sie hat gar keine frage die man sich
vorstellen kann die politik denn jetzt
rechnen kann die politik nicht rechnen
sollte die politik vielleicht wirklich
hier als anregung unter ihrem wagen
strich machen so teuer wird die nummer
also ich gehe davon aus dass die politik
rechnen kann wir haben viele ministerien
mit vielen vielen tausend
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern wie
wir wissen und ich denke die frage was
für eine politik man macht es am ende
eine frage des politischen willens wir
haben bei verschiedenen krisen der
vergangenen jahre fest gestellt dass wir
große entscheidungen in diesem land
innerhalb von wenigen wochen treffen
können wenn wir es wollen und insofern
ist die antwort für mich relativ klar
also die also einer der scheidung
atomausstiegs kurz mal einen diese
entscheidungen diese stadt also in japan
da passiert und tsunami bei uns
verstehen die so viel sondern ich und
schwuppdiwupp thomas sehen das ist wie
ein schönes beispiel für
hat eigentlich mit rationalität nichts
zu tun so ist das manchmal ja ich würde
sagen da wir jetzt schon so oft über
harburg und auch atomausstieg zeige ich
ihnen noch einen ganz kurzen film wieder
von der haar beckum nochmal zu zeigen
forschung ist hier sind wie dramatisch
die lage eigentlich wirklich ist gerade
für unser land je nachdem also welche
verträge sie haben machen sie mit jedem
tag mit jeder woche ein - und sollte
dieses - so groß werden dass die
unternehmen ist nicht mehr tragen können
und sie umfallen droht der gesamte markt
irgendwann umzufallen also einen
basiseffekt im energiesystem die
versorger wie die stadtwerke nicht mehr
die stadtwerke nicht mehr die
nachgelagerten kunden und dann kann man
sich vorstellen was dann in deutschland
passiert frauchen gerät passt zu ihrer
these was er habe vielleicht tun sollte
jetzt
die lage in deutschland ist dramatisch
viele unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
sorgen sich um ihre zukunft viele
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher sind
jetzt schon schwerlich imstande die
kosten die sie wöchentlich monatlich
jährlich haben speisten bei der frage
wie wir dieses land mit energie mit
strom mit wärme versorgen können
brauchen zurzeit die köpfe die grünen
haben sich über die maßen angestrengt
jetzt wieder die fossilen energien in
deutschland voranzubringen und die
kohleverstromung wieder voranzubringen
heute ist die zweite alarmstufe beim
plan für gas ausgesprochen worden was
robert habeck allerdings nicht macht ist
tatsächlich alle energetischen
alternativen zu prüfen und dazu zählt
natürlich der atomstrom diese atomstrom
ist durchaus betreiber die drei
atomkraftwerke sind weiterhin betreibt
war auch die die bereits abgeschaltet
wurden können reaktiviert werden
rechtliche argumente hinter denen man
sich versteckt sind völlig haltlos auch
die frage wo kriegt man die brennstäbe
her sind gerade zuletzt heute vom tüv
süd widerlegt worden also wenn robert
habeck über seinen schatten springen
würde und nicht so viel ideologie in
seiner energiepolitik walten lassen
würde dann würden wir in der frage wie
wir in den herbst gehen zum tag heute
deutlich besser dastehen mehr
interessant ist natürlich die
beobachtung dass wir immer sagt gesagt
bekommen von den damen und herren die
die korona politik oder jetzt die
energiepolitik exekutieren alles wird
sich ändern nichts wird bleiben wie es
war die welt nach krone und nach der
ukraine krieg wird anders sein als zuvor
und der druck verharre die beobachtungen
ist ja richtig die grüne partei mit erna
berg an der spitze bisher bei diesem
dogma nicht rütteln am atomausstieg also
alles soll sich ändern aber das bitte
schön ich das ist natürlich und
vernünftig es wäre eine pointe der
geschichte wenn du jetzt gerade die
grüne partei rückgängig machen würde was
und das muss ich natürlich schon
vorhalten was schwarz-gelb der mann ins
werk gesetzt also eine dem namen nach
dem namen nach konservative regierung
angeführt von der stimmungs politikerin
frau merkel hat mitbekommen weit weit
weg hinten in japan ist etwas passiert
ein seebeben und weil deutschland ihn so
viel mehren liegt müssen wir hier jetzt
die atomkraft schnell mal abschalten
gleiches adhoc system natürlich auch wir
bei der aussetzung der wehrkraft japan
demonstration untersagt war der auslöser
dieses kopflose sao tomé handeln ja ein
vater die dinger gebaut und schüttet
heute noch kommen aber das geht jetzt
dass wir diesen letzten endes natürlich
sagen muss also die müssen jetzt mal
schnellster im pott kommen um einen
fehler zu beheben den wir also wir als
cdu maßgeblich mit zu verantworten haben
und ich glaube nicht dass heute eine
energie oder ein umweltminister wer
vorher hieß namens altmaier dass
eventuell ein kanzler laschet heute
sofort die atommeiler wieder einstellen
würde der wird sich auch veranstaltungs
kurz zurück rufen also ich glaube zurück
beziehen also ich glaube mit einer
anderen regierung werden die gleichen
probleme darunter würden gleich heute
die grünen sagen mal gucken was herr
laschet jetzt wir sind uns doch in der
sache einig und wir verurteilen robert
habeck nicht für das was andere
regierungen vor jahren mal entschieden
haben
wie fähig ist politik heute wie fähig
ist diese ampel regierung auf eine
aktuelle krise zu reagieren die dieses
land praktisch gegen die wand fahren
kann im herbst und im winter sie können
sich das also wir können uns das glaube
ich alle nicht vorstellen was uns hier
bevorsteht jetzt geht nicht nur darum
dass die heizung vielleicht aus ist oder
dass wir kalt duschen müssen es geht um
die funktionalität unserer gesamten
deutschen industrie und das ist das wäre
ein irreparabler baustellen er sich sie
noch eine ehrensache fragen
zurückblicken haben wir gerade zurück
auf die zeit der union als
regierungspartei aber es gibt ja auch
eine eine wahrheit über die man auch
sprechen muss treffen russland die
sanktionen vielleicht gar nicht so stark
wie wir dachten oder wie die neue
regierung ist dachte wie ist jetzt
deutschland trifft wenn man jetzt auf
gas wieder schaut also nach den uns
vorliegenden informationen treffen
russland die sanktionen sehr sehr wohl
aber russland ist natürlich auch ein
stark der versucht wie können wir durch
diese krise da kommen und was können wir
alternativ auf die beine stellen und am
ende wird sich zeigen wer den längeren
atem hat
über sanktion betrifft also ich sie
werden langfristig würde mich
kurzfristige lösung man kann natürlich
sanktionen vor dem krieg beenden die es
nicht gegeben also ist das halte ich für
völlig illusorisch würde funktionieren
das problem ist wir haben es folgendes
gas ist ein wichtiger prozess stoff in
der industrie chemische industrie und
wir haben als zurzeit wir sind sehr
aktiv dabei die automobilindustrie platt
zu machen durch verbrenner verboten
ähnliches im nächsten schritt machen wir
die chemische industrie platz ist nicht
mehr kostenmäßig wettbewerbsfähig die
wird den usa produzieren in china
produzieren die standorte gibt es auch
schon dort gibt es belege energie und
bei uns nicht und das ist nicht nur
momentaner schock in diesem winter
sondern es gibt strukturell an die
substanz und sie haben vorhin so schön
waren vorgerechnet ihr einkommen pro
kopf wo haben wir eine gute einkommen
pro kopf in der automobilindustrie und
der chemieindustrie oder diese beiden
industrien verlieren da haben wir einen
massiven wohlstandsverlust das ist
völlig ausgeblendet und vor dem
hintergrund angst dieser dramatik bin
ich bei ihnen dann müsste nicht durch
die atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
wolle die drei jahre funktionsfähig sind
weil das vor wochen ausgeschaltet wurden
wieder anschalten
das ist der eindruck der nächste aspekt
scheint es nicht nur ein schalter das
ist der ist ja alles ernst da brauchen
wir auch haben oder die brennstoffe
zugesagt sorgen
aber es lohnt sich das zu tun übrigens
wer sie kennt wenn wir diese nutzen
würde perspektive schon wasserstoff zu
erzeugen weil man die energiewende
wirklich machen will braucht man der
wasserstoff und in der zeit wo geht's
weiter was zumal es werden liegend aber
das ist wie gesagt wegen ideologie nicht
möglich ein aspekt macht wie hat sich
nun halten die haben wir nichts zu essen
so ist es weil die
nahrungsmittelindustrie im hohen maße
von gas abhängt also becker also der
bäcker alles dramatisch ist jetzt die
lage die situation ist dramatisch an
umfassenden weil diese die sich jeder in
sich dramatisch wir haben wir haben
weltweit auch noch probleme haben
weltweit das hungerproblem dazu müssten
wir alles tun um die
nahrungsmittelproduktion in deutschland
zu fördern machen wir nicht weil wir
legen lieber die flächen stellen wir
müssten dringend alles tun um jede
kilowattstunde sparen sagt der bäcker
auch machen wir nicht weil atomkraft ist
ja bu
aber trotzdem finde ich jetzt kleinen
kleinen einspruch haben das doch etwas
zu apokalyptisch jetzt also sie haben
gesagt wir machen ganz chemieindustrie
kaputt also basf ist die grösste
industrie und energieunternehmen
chemieunternehmen der welt meines
wissens also das wird jetzt nicht platt
von diesem halt nein ich kann sagen
chinesische die gesamte
automobilindustrie wird auch nicht platt
gemacht die wird sich teilweise
transformieren ich hoffe vielleicht auch
neu erfinden also mit einem halben jahr
ist nicht die kindliche beiden tragenden
inter ergeht oder einfach ein traum da
sie denken dass nach dem halben jahr
wieder billige energie haben wir haben
auf dauer keine billige energie mehr das
modell war billiges gas aus russland
versorgt die industrie hier das ist es
nicht mehr wenn wir allen flüssiggas
haben wenn sie überhaupt kriegen wenn
die amerikaner als ob noch nie von ihm
selber treu preisen liefern die nicht
mehr wenn dir oder kann ist muss man ja
kommen das ist klimaschädlich hoch zehn
das heer zu transferieren ich und wenn
es hier so teuer es ist ein kostenfaktor
ist ein halbes jahr wenn ich jetzt in
der ceo von basf wäre und ich haben
statt den usa ich habe riesen stand und
in china meist der größte standort nicht
in ludwigs haben sondern in china und
ich frage mich wo liegt die zukunft als
die zukunft nicht in dem land mit den
höchsten strompreise die wir schon vor
monaten schon im vorfeld hatten das ist
einfach weg das ist das so ein schuss
ins knie und dafür finde ich ist der
havag extrem entspannt die
hauptbetroffenen in die kamera und sagt
ich bin ja nicht dran schuld nicht
stimmten thomas steg nicht gemacht ohne
die grünen
aber immer so mit seinem schmalen mund
als er kommt erich und 1 der welt
ich habe es nicht mit den grünen das tut
mir leid das ist ich hab' ich bin eine
leistungsgesellschaft groß geworden ich
kann nur mit intelligenten menschen muss
anfang halbwegs
seit die medien ja ihr wisst sowas darum
läuft das ist das fragt sich manchmal
wie die im normalen leben zurechtkommen
ich will mir die probezeit ist ja einige
politiker nicht spiele gewinnen ich
schätze einige produkte erzeugen doch
ich kann
die
süddeutsche zeitung schrieb heute habe
ich mache zurzeit alles perfekt also die
meinungen gehen wirklich sehr
auseinander und nochmal ich ich ich
teile ihre diagnose doch erstellter ich
will jetzt gar nicht sagen die machen
alles richtig machen das meist falsch
machen vieles falsch aber ich glaube
dass diese apocalyptic wenn wir uns da
hineinsteigern jetzt uns auch nicht
weiter bringt katastrophen treten dann
noch schneller einen gefestigten anderen
als andersrum wir müssen jetzt panik
haben damit wir da doch wir müssen jetzt
panik haben damit sie im herbst nicht so
schlechter geht und ich sage ihnen wir
haben noch nicht genug das ist ein wenig
verbreitet nein noch mal ich habe vorhin
gesagt wir haben in diesem mai 22 so
viel gas verbrannt für stromer soll wie
noch nie in der geschichte deutschlands
dass ich ihnen das ein steak nasa
verstecke noch ein statement von mir
also es ist nicht so dass die apokalypse
uns von heute auf morgen überrollt in
allen lebensbereichen das ist nicht der
fall aber es geht stück für stück für
stück und zwar seit jahren wir haben
keine fachkräfte mehr wir haben keine
arbeitskräfte mehr unternehmen können
nicht mehr arbeiten weil ihnen die leute
fehlen die die situation ist dramatisch
corona ist noch immer nicht überwunden
in den bilanzen der unternehmen gestern
gerade erst sagte ein hotelier er
braucht sind zehn jahre um die verluste
aus kohle wieder zu erarbeiten das ist
unvorstellbar und das hast du dir auch
manchmal mithören im mund und
realisieren was eigentlich harmlos und
ihre partei hat die guten jahre nicht
genutzt das land wiesenfest omar ist es
eben so dass herr stelter meinte dass
panik jetzt auch wichtig ist um den
ernst der lage nicht bei der politik
muss haben wir die sorry sie waren daran
aber nicht ich möchte keine panik bei
den zuschauern verbreiten oder erfolg
aber die regierung muss zu handeln als
kommt das schloss der fünfte fall war
dann kann die jetzt noch die richtigen
maßnahmen greifen schauen sie also
erstelle ich habe jetzt panik nach
dieser sendung na ja sie mit der polizei
über machen der eine sache wenn die iren
dem ich jetzt nicht ihren job macht und
dann haben wir da taten bitteren also in
der nick trifft man keine guten
entscheidungen aber man soll jeder
realistisch man sollte realistisch die
lage bewerten und danach handeln und das
schlimme ist dass wir gerade in fragen
der strom energieversorgung zum teil
auch ideologisch regiert werden ja und
eben nicht objektiv und das wäre gerade
in so einer krise
war ein crooner kann man immer das
stichwort der ganze instrumentenkasten
muss auf dem tisch der muss ja auf den
tisch gelegt der nicht auf den tisch so
ist das ist das problem sei nicht
eingeladen weil hier bürgern bin ja dann
hört doch auf die wir sollten wenn bei
mir war es nicht funktioniert der firma
und flur rede ist und es bringt nichts
ja dann hat man meinen stiefel im
hintern damit funktioniert und dann mal
redet öfter mal überlegt sie was es gibt
konsequenzen
ja natürlich natürlich was das ist doch
dieser unterschied der einen wahnsinnig
macht wo man sagt ihr konzert treiben
was willst
wunsch sie auch ein frosch im ko und an
die politik dass auch mehr konsequenz
und gibt und damit noch einen schönen
abend zu hause wenn sie mögen nächste
woche dienstag abend sind wir wieder für
sie da
[Musik]